okay well yeah I mean I don't know I
guess sometimes I can be an [ __ ] but
really it's like I not really good in
social situations sometimes I don't put
forth and effort yeah and yeah that's
why usually I don't go out because then
it's like if I'm gonna be an [ __ ] I'd
rather just not go out and just stand if
I don't have the like the strength and
the energy to be nice to people yeah I
got I kind of went through something
like that like back home before I moved
like I just wasn't enjoying being like
home or the situation I was in so I was
just like whenever I would go out and do
anything I would just be miserable and
just like you know come across as real
dickish or [ __ ] you know like
um but then like I don't know moved here
and just forced myself to go out and be
a little better in social situations and
introduce myself I think it's better
here at people here like more fun and
cooler yeah everyone seems real real
chill around here yeah it's been a good
time since I moved here I'm coming up on
a year now so
in Austin yeah wow yeah you moved after
me I remember you coming in yeah you
were the
you're the reason I stood on the creek
in the cage uh Creek in the cave stage
for the first time just because you were
like can you help me sound check because
I got night because I had just moved
here like that week because that was the
four Open Mic no it was for your dating
show like I went in I didn't even know
and I just went that's when we first
Sunday on Sunday that's when we first
like actually met I just walked in
because I was gonna go there just do
some writing and check it out yeah and
then I show up and then like you're like
there and I was like oh [ __ ] Hans like
because I'd seen you like online and a
friend of mine's a big fan of yours back
home so yeah but not you she likes my
comedy I mean like you're not a fan of
me oh I hadn't seen it at that point oh
dude your writing's great I like this
man I mean you're killing it you have
good sets sometimes better than mine I
try you know I do I just go up and do my
job competition it's not like yeah but
yeah I mean uh I remember that night I
thought you were just like a normal
person or no I don't know what I thought
but I was like oh I've never seen this
guy before yeah and it's like weird
because now I see you all the time yeah
yeah and then we started and then you
taught me how to play Catan yeah I'm
gonna play kitten a couple times which I
haven't been able to come into the games
just recently or being able to go is
just because of the early mornings at
the gym you know we're in there I
appreciate it because every time you
can't come you tell everyone hey I can't
come yeah and then nobody expects you
there yeah that's nice it's like it
starts a nice train of like people that
can't come yeah it's like oh yeah you
can't come well then it's okay that I
don't come oh [ __ ] yeah that makes sense
that's where you're like hey you don't
have to respond every time
I just appreciate it people think I'm an
[ __ ] yeah yeah I get it though as
soon as you decided it clicked I was
like oh yeah then everybody else is just
because it's funny because it's just
gonna blow up and then it becomes the
whole message of who's not going yeah
it's like negative it's like a no train
and Pick Up Artist circles it's called
the yes train if you start questions
that they have to say yes to then
they're more likely to say yes later on
yeah like if you like to have fun right
yeah yeah you like
yeah you got colors do you want to do
Molly food uh sure you want to take some
GHB
but yeah I mean uh do you have you ever
gone into the pickup artists world no I
haven't I never went down that rabbit
hole of you've been you've been watching
some videos and what they do hell yeah
trying to get trying to get that game
trick [ __ ] turn trick them and just
learn the skills and learn how to
acquire what you want yeah that's that
famous line I think Rodney Dangerfield
said it I heard Joe Rogan say Rodney
Dangerfield said it where he's like
tricked him again
or has fooled them again after a show
yeah that's funny just like um
Chappelle's joke where he's like guys
buy nice things because women like nice
things like oh nice porch gotcha [ __ ]
I love his joke about uh like women that
dress up and they're like and you know
it's never a woman's fault if she gets
uh you know I forget what it was but if
you're if I go up to a man is dressed up
like a policeman
and he's like excuse me sir just because
I'm dressed like this yeah that's a good
one yeah it's like uh like no matter
like even if you're at like a place
where everyone's trying to date each
other like a singles meet up girls will
never admit that they're there to meet
someone yeah like if you're at a
basketball court like they're there to
play basketball but
um like yeah there's no place to go
where like this is exclusively for
dating and you don't want a date don't
come here yeah it's like going to a like
a singles mixer and just like oh sorry
no I'm not looking for anything
well that's part of their game it's like
their ability to say no is a large part
of their power and uh that's true in a
meet up you ever set now yeah it's I
mean you feel powerful right it happens
you're like yeah no you're like I feel
good about myself yeah I don't need you
my life is amazing without you it's true
but I think that's a bad attitude I
think we should come together more and
create communities and organizations so
that we can collectively bargain
collectively bargain yeah get rid of the
dollar yeah just barter everything yeah
the ethereum based economy ethereum you
into all that you got some of that me
neither I don't think that's how you're
supposed to use it yeah I think we're
supposed to use it like without thinking
about it if you have to think about it
then it's like what's the point of it
yeah it's like you have to spend so much
money thinking about the currency that's
right you're going through like all
right and you really have to want
something that's only available by
purchase of that to use it because it's
like you have to go through like 45
steps yeah
they make it difficult
but I hope that it'll be the future
Monday Monday
yeah yeah I was like I got into it for a
little bit when I was like when the
whole nft thing was coming out I was
learning about it and then then I was
because I was thinking of turning like
the like my paintings in the nfts I just
never followed through with it but it
was a lot of steps just to even set it
up before I could even like put money
into it and I was like oh this seems
like a lot of work yeah it's supposed to
be better than money not worse yeah what
uh what paintings
um I do alcohol ink paintings it's um
like alcohol it's a it's called alcohol
ink and it's just like basically ink and
then I use uh rubbing alcohol yeah and I
just um put it on this thin paper called
yubo paper it's like a non-absorbent
non-porous paper and then a German
submarine yeah yes exactly is that what
it's from no um U-Boat oh yupo oh you po
so y-u-p-o okay so you have a specific
medium that you specialize in yeah and
just do that and then I used to and then
once it's liquid on the paper then I use
like a uh an air air dryer and just and
I just you know I manipulate it and
until it comes out to like a cool
painting or something I think
I think
um I haven't showed you this but yeah
you could check it out on a boy named
Leslie on Instagram that's my painting
one I mean but that's cool
stuff like that
oh it's colorful yeah it's real colorful
and abstract
okay and you have like a comedy one too
and comedy yeah that's just for like my
art you know it's
what I did like uh
got into that over
um got into that over uh
over covid and then I just started
painting and because I originally got
off like social media and when code
happened I got off social media
completely I deleted like everything
because it was like I didn't know when
comedy was coming back and then I got
into painting and then I started sharing
those I got so then I got an Instagram
for that and that was my main account
for a little bit over covet so you were
like [ __ ] comedy well it was yeah who
knew when it was coming back I needed
some kind of release and painting if it
was like six months later you're like I
regret it yeah I did regret it because
then they like everything this comedy
started coming back and I had basically
I had to start over from scratch lost
all my contacts like through all those
years of doing shows like you know
that's how I felt when I moved to New
York I was like [ __ ] Seattle I'm out of
here I'm going to go to New York and
make it big and forget about all you
people
and then I got to New York and I was
like oh [ __ ] if if I had chosen Seattle
that'd be nice if I could fly back yeah
um but yeah I mean you uh you kind of
called it early on Comedy you're like
covet destroyed comedy comedy sucks I'm
gonna well it wasn't that it was just
more of like the distraction of worrying
about posting like it was just like it
was just a nice break nice mental
cleanse you know it was stuck at the
house you know going nuts sitting on
social media you know it's just like I
took a break and I'd in retrospect that
she was going crazy right everyone had
their opinions on what we should do and
shouldn't do yeah exactly and you
couldn't escape it in retrospect I
should have just deactivated it and then
restarted it later but I was like you
can like do a middle ground yeah or just
not or delete the app and keep that
count up exactly yes but you know I
committed it was dramatic it was
dramatic and I fully committed made a
statement you were like [ __ ] you guys
and honestly I mean it was nice it was
really nice I mean if it wasn't for
comedy I don't think I would really mess
with social media at all yeah like it
was it was a really nice I mean I had a
good routine covered was nice for that
like got a good routine it was eating
right just sleeping right working out
all the time like
doing my painting and it was going well
and it was the painting was cool because
I was just doing it for fun and it's
like every time I would post a picture
I'd have like at least three or four
people that I knew messaging me asking
to buy it yeah so I was like I was
pretty every time I'd post them when
someone would buy it back home at least
you know that's cool and every time I
would uh every time I'd sell one I would
just up the price 50 bucks for the next
one and then it just
that's a good way to do it yeah because
then it's like you get to a limit and
you're like okay now they are not buying
it and then you find out what price
works for you exactly and then people
would ask me for commissions like
special stuff like they'd be like I like
these colors can you make me one like
this but yeah sure and then
make a couple paintings and I would I
would only make I would only make them
11 by 14 or smaller yeah do you could do
like sets of like smaller ones or sets
of like uh 11 by 14 but I wouldn't go
anywhere does it help your accommodate
do you feel like it's the same muscle no
not not for not in the same not in the
same sense of like working out and being
funny and being quick up here but it's
the same it was it was the the closest
thing to the end like the level of
enjoyment I get from you know being on
stage like just doing something creating
something I feel like it's the same
thing it's in many ways uh we find the
similarities the core
the you know the the thing that we're
doing is the same and it's about other
people really like you want to bring
happiness to their life with color yeah
that was true because I mean when people
would be like oh I really love that or
like leave a comment or just message me
hey can I buy that that made me feel
good you know I was like oh man I made
this and someone else gets enjoyment out
of it you know yeah so it is the same as
like in that regard yeah it's so crazy
like every everything in like America is
about like individual and selfishness
but like even when you're being selfish
it's really about other people yeah like
if you want to be a rock star it's like
you want to play music for other people
so yeah you're playing I mean you do a
little bit for yourself but you're doing
it for the rock star reasons and then
other people get enjoyment out of which
only makes it better for you yeah
yeah I mean uh so what do you think
about like hanging out with a girl
and then she's like I don't want to have
sex with you and then you're like I
don't want to hang out with her anymore
well I mean if you've made your
intentions clear like if it's like a
dating situation but I mean like
I mean I've had I've had moments in my
life where I've been interested in
friends of mine and then it's not
reciprocated you know and I mean it's
not that I don't hang out with them
anymore but eventually it just dies off
anyway you know yeah so I mean it's not
like the only thing that I want women
for is to [ __ ] them but if that's
something
that uh
I want from them and then it doesn't
happen then it's like feelings can get
hurt and like I don't want to hang out
with them or if that's like the only
value that they have is like their
sexuality and I don't like their
personality that much or they're too
volatile and they're not gonna [ __ ] me
then I don't really want to hang out
with them that's true
dude when do you think you're gonna get
past the point uh
wanting to have sex with them just
because there's because of their
sexuality like wouldn't you rather have
sex with someone that you enjoy their
personality as well yeah ideally yeah
um yeah I mean but if like there's
someone that's on the borderline and
then they the sex is on the table then
it makes it easier to get along with
them but yeah I get that yeah it does
it's yeah I just uh do you think that's
a little uh little like um
like not I don't care I'm thinking of
the right term but it's not I mean it's
obviously not beer goggles but like sex
goggles it's like you know it's like
you're the only thing that I see in
people is their sex organs no not that
just like when you are interested in
somebody like oh yeah is it easier to
put up with like more attractive or yeah
they just seen the table and then when
it's off you're like oh this person
sucks yeah you're like oh this person
sucks yeah yeah
um yeah I mean I think that's true I
just think that uh women
um can be just as shitty as men oh yeah
definitely yeah yeah and they use
sexuality as a weapon to get ahead and
when it comes time for them to cash in
they're like no I'd rather not I'd
rather get all the benefits without
having to
have orgasms and it's like it's a very
transactional and it's very selfish and
I think like uh it's like uh with
anything you know like it's all about
competition and about trying to like get
ahead and use whatever tools that you
can your race your gender and then like
having to pay as few prices as possible
to get that yeah but not everyone not
everyone is like that but it is a lot it
is very very frequent it's like it's
rare to find someone that's not like
using all the the tools in there or all
the weapons in their Arsenal you know
yeah it's gross like especially if
you're like Trump and you're a white
dude and you're all about winning you're
gonna use race to get ahead yeah you're
gonna [ __ ] on Mexicans to get ahead and
get white people to love you that's true
and it's that's why people who are all
about winning and getting ahead are kind
of like toxic people because there's no
no they only think about themselves and
it's like well they yeah whole
capitalistic like uh competitiveness you
know of everything like that does get in
some people's heads and you know a lot
of people do that that's the only thing
that's important to them is winning like
it's like kill or be killed you know
some you know that's what all those Wall
Street dudes I think like Wolf of Wall
Street what's his name uh Gordon Gekko
Gordon Gekko all those dudes you know
they all had that mentality yeah they
all had that mentality it's like I'm the
best I'm gonna be the best and I'm gonna
do anything to get there you know yeah
you can't make a community or a society
out of that no you can
yeah I just um
um you know like uh I I think like uh
yeah like I uh I don't like hanging out
with people that are too like conniving
and like lizard-like and just only
thinking about their own success and
trying to get ahead at all costs well no
of course like you want to hang out with
people that you connect with that you
enjoy and then if they're like them they
won't have sex with me then I don't want
to hang out then that's true
yeah but yeah I'm very sex obsessed and
I'm very like pursuant
have you always been sex obsessed
because I kind of happened yeah yeah I
mean it's been important to me for a
while yeah and then I don't think that
the game is fair and I don't think that
my opponents are playing fairly yeah so
now that I have an advantage like
why don't I play the game the same way
that women have been playing the game if
they're gonna be grumpy and gloomy and
negative and still get laid and still
have relationships and like what if I am
gloomy and grumpy and like to see the
worst in people like what what kind of
society would that be it wouldn't but
what
what do you think or why do you think or
why do you want to be the dark and
gloomy guy because I used to be that guy
like and now I'm like here and I'm like
you're actually pretty happy like you're
better than me I'm not better than you
I'm better than I was right but which is
where I'm at according to you well just
I mean you're just I can relate to that
feeling too like you know but at some
point you just I mean I made the
conscious decision it was like I don't
want to be like this anymore I want to
like put effort into it and like when I
moved here like I I had like well it's
good to be a good person and happy and
[ __ ] but if you're just a happy good
person and everyone else is just
[ __ ] on you and taking advantage of
it then it's not worth it to give people
the benefit of the doubt and be nice to
them that's true I mean you could still
be happy and and happy and go lucky but
you know you don't have to let people
walk on you either that's yeah just be
firm in your beliefs and your well if
you're too firm then people think that's
being an [ __ ] but I just feel like
it's like we there it was an affair
trial it was an affair like assessment
of who I am it's just instinctively no
and let me see uh some other things that
I can get like the the value judgment
that women place I don't think was fair
and I resent that and I resent their
treatment of me and now like I uh I try
to avoid that kind of situation like I'm
with a girl right now who's really nice
and you know there's no [ __ ] and
she's like showing me positivity and
approval and it's like for so long it's
just been disapproval and so I just try
to avoid all that [ __ ] like that's the
one thing that I like is like I don't
want to uh
open myself up to that and like girls
think that just because you want to [ __ ]
them that they can be shitty to you oh
yeah no they shouldn't you know right
and those are the girls you shouldn't
even which is unfair to categorize half
the people and be like this is what you
guys did to me yeah so I'm gonna treat
half the population shitty but I just
feel like whenever you're in that Arena
and whatever girls
uh meet someone that's a dude they're
just like they need to treat you shitty
just so that you don't try to [ __ ] them
because they don't like sex they don't
they don't think it's a good thing and
it's just like they they look at it as a
transaction and they try to get as much
from sex as possible yeah and it's about
survival to them it's like they're still
a Victorian era type of thinking about
sex and I don't know I just uh
I guess I don't I resent uh women and
their assessment of me
uh and I I don't know I just uh
I don't know what I'm saying
now when you're with like your new lady
that you that that likes you shows you
positivity and you know appreciation
like do you when that's happening you're
not thinking about all that other stuff
you're are you you're feeling good or
you're happy in the moment and just like
and all that stuff's pretty much let go
you know so now the key is just remember
things that shit's all washed away it's
over and done with it's in the past it's
just time to move on and create the best
experience for yourself moving forward
like in life
yeah
yeah it's important to do that I just
think that there's like a air of
negativity with the sex thing yeah I
mean there can be for sure yeah I mean
it's gonna be one or the other either
like in general overall everyone's gonna
be in a good place or a bad place and I
think like overall
it's just like I feel like when women
look at people they just are like
what can I get out of them the worst in
people and like it's not a very loving
compassionate place
that they're creating that's true and I
think like uh
it's a
it's like they're just like
using the Beauty and the love that they
have natural access to and using it for
their selfish desires partly because
they're there's no social safety net and
they have to to get ahead and I think if
we had like Universal Health Care and
like treated people decently then they
wouldn't have to live in such a hard
scramble world where they had to use
their beauty and sex to get ahead but I
think at the end of the day the result
is that they're like negative
like
critical people
that I don't think that uh I've I value
their I don't value their judgment very
highly okay
all right
I just want to get that off my chest but
you feel better yeah I just like yeah I
don't care about that game and I'm I'm
glad like I can skirt around it and be
like [ __ ] you guys this this is this is
a stupid game and I'm not even gonna try
and be more successful at it than
you idiots that's true you do have a you
have a nice slight Advantage you know
but maybe you think also just with the
success and you know being in the
entertainment world you know there's a
lot of people out there that want to be
in that world and so that's why they do
try and use that to get into that world
you know like you're saying but outside
of the Entertainment Circle there are a
lot of good people a lot of good girls
out there you know yeah it's just not
set up for us to meet like that's true I
mean it's difficult for you now it's
like the good people are never the ones
that go out of the way to like approach
people it's always like the aggressive
like people that need it the most who
are the most desperate they're like hi I
noticed that you where did you get that
dress yeah what do you what number are
you thinking of yeah that's I mean just
I don't know I have a different
experience you know yeah you're very you
got a good you know like I think people
look at you and they're like oh no
matter what I throw at him he's gonna be
a okay like it's very you're unshakable
people think that they can like be
whatever they are around you and it
won't affect you that's nice yeah I mean
I kind of take people as they are and
maybe maybe that's true but I don't know
it was funny like someone saw me up I
was I was really frustrated the other
day because I was having some issues
with like the podcast with some editing
stuff and I was like frustrated and like
once I was just I always I was like man
I'm so mad right now I'm so frustrated
this won't work in like one of the other
Comics told me and then like I was
talking to him yesterday and he goes he
goes uh that was like the most mat I've
ever seen you and all I said was like
I'm so upset you know yeah
it's scary because you're usually calm
and if you are not then it's like holy
[ __ ] he's really blowing a fuse right
now
yeah no I mean I think I'm pretty
relaxed I just kind of go with the flow
on a lot of things and just observe and
like things that bother most people
don't bother you but if but if there's
something that bothers you then it
really bothers me yeah I'm just like oh
that Paul because you let so much slide
off your back yeah
so you what do you think what are you
what is your dating history like you've
you've uh played it cool and easy no I
mean I was
I mean let's see
like um when I was like four years old I
found my dad's Hustler stash like his
stack of hustlers so yeah he's so young
yeah for like hardcore porn and like I
found that and I kept that a secret for
like I don't know like until I was like
13 when like I couldn't realize I could
sell them to my friends for money you
know in middle school but like I was
like I was I was always been looking at
porn since I was like like four years
old super like hypersexualized but I
didn't lose my virginity until I was
like 17. but I would always get caught
like in elementary school getting
playing doctor with like the girls at
school or the girls play yeah basically
not knowing what I was doing you know
but just imitating what I saw in these
magazines you know yeah
um and then and then I've like I've had
a few really I've probably had about
maybe three or four serious
relationships and then the rest of the
time I've pretty much been mostly single
like my whole life you know just going
around and when I was 22 I started with
22 23 started working out and getting
fit and then I had like my like whole
face you know and just went just went
and just partied and did all that wasn't
and then uh mellowed out went got back
into school
graduated from college and then just
it's been kind of single like my last
relationship ended in like 2019 and that
was like a year and a half two years-ish
and
I've been single ever since and just I
don't know let's do it was your sex life
nowaday of like a lot of one-night
stands no I have a girlfriend right now
and I kind of just that's your last
relation that's your latest relationship
latest relationship yeah it's like I
have a girlfriend right now we've been
seeing each other for about four or five
months yeah she's good yeah she lives
about an hour away which is nice because
it's like close enough she comes up once
a week and visits and hangs around the
city uh Temple okay she lives up in
Temple is that North uh north of Texas
yeah my girl lives in San Antonio so I'm
in a similar situation yeah I like it
though because it's like I still get
it's alone time get my alone time
um because if she was close then we
might always be together and we might
never get anything done oh yeah I do get
those vibes from like my situation as
well sometimes you know but um we do
hang out a bit and sometimes she stays a
little longer than we planned on it but
it's like it's not like it's bothering
me that she's there because I'm enjoying
the time it's just an outfit words I
have a lot of playing catch up to do
with like certain things and like there
are fun just distracting you Sam but it
was a good distraction yeah
until she starts nagging yeah but that
hasn't happened yet it doesn't don't see
any signs of that coming on so I mean
she's in Temple
yeah far away you can drown out you can
mute and turn the volume down
yeah it's just I get my alone time and
she comes up and we spend time together
when she comes up I give her the
attention and like I you know she comes
out with me to shows if I if I'm booked
on the show I go out and do my show and
she'll come and then like there's other
times where it's like hey you can not
coming up this week I got things to do
like I've chose to go to and I want to
go and go and do my own thing you know
and she's cool with that and she gets it
that's good yeah yeah I mean I think uh
dating can be hard
and the world can be unfair and like
where I think there's a problem with uh
Society right now we're not we're not
connecting and we're not like loving
each other as much as we could yeah and
it sucks being like a straight dude yeah
that's like average looking but like
what would be worse is like an ugly girl
like there they have the hardest I do
they really do I mean but if you're a
High girl it's like a gamble you know
they get everything or nothing yeah it's
and so it's how they decide to work work
with their Weaponry right yeah whatever
you're gifted with yeah
but yeah I mean if you're an ugly girl
you can always find
a dude that is willing to [ __ ] you I'm
sure yeah if that's what you're looking
for if that's all you need is like just
a dildo basically I mean you gotta
remember there's ugly guys out there too
yeah and the ugly guys that don't have
money but if you want something more
yeah
but you know that's why they say you
know
it's not all about looks some people
find happiness with the person and I
mean I'm I'm I like to think that I like
go for more personality I like to engage
with and have sex with people that I
like actually enjoy being around and
have at least the mildness of a
connection with you know yeah it's
always good to have looks though I agree
that's right yeah I'm a child I'm
shallow too
yeah
yeah I mean it sucks being a dude but I
think being an ugly girl is way worse
so it's like
I think it's gonna be complaining yeah
but I mean it doesn't have to be like a
competition I think like overall there's
like a lack of love in our society
and I think it's like because we
practice hating each other yeah there's
a lot of a lot of hate out there yeah
what do you think that is because I know
I I mean I don't know but I I think I
know you think honestly I think like
especially like online with like
comments and stuff where it's like
there's no consequence so it's like
people can just be as mean as they want
but isn't that a symptom like that's
just what happens when there's a lot of
hate out is that a lot of hate gets
spewed out on a communication platform
well yeah it's just like the saying like
you are who you hang out with you know
like I mean people don't hang out with
people they sit on the internet all day
full of trolls and see all this [ __ ]
talking and hate and all this stuff
that's what they're gonna be around so
they're going to be like but that's like
saying like because they're around hate
they're gonna have hate but what causes
the hate what causes the struggle and
the friction
I think it's a lot of just a lot of
different things like could be like a
single individual's insecurity about
something so then but what about love
like if people around love they're gonna
spread more love yeah they're on hey
they're going to spread more hate so why
is it that we have more hate Than Love
I mean the world is just a cruel a cruel
place you know things happen you know we
live in a nice partisan we live in a
part a section of society that's nice
and cushy and nervous and still there's
a lot of hate here and there's still a
lot of hate you know so you think it's
just natural that humans are just
hateful and just vicious I think it has
to do just come through with maybe like
more of a nature nurture over nature you
know kind of thing or nurtured how they
were nurtured yeah different cultures
may have different levels of hate
comments yeah like it seems like I mean
when I grew up with my stepdad was a
like a big biker dude and he was pretty
Prejudiced and I grew up around a bunch
of just racist jokes all the time I'm
Italian and German okay so but my
stepdad raised me since I was like 18
months old like he was married to myself
someone with the Hustler magazines all
right that's my real dad because like my
whole my whole perspective on life is
like I just grew up with two families
like my parents were divorced and like
one was the Hustler porn addicted dad
the other was a racist biker yeah
exactly you know so I grew up but it was
like the same thing I grew up around
that a lot and we lived out in the
country so it was just like
predominantly whites and Mexican people
and um so you know when I was like 18 19
you know growing up in high school I
thought that [ __ ] was funny and then
and then as you like move out and get
and start meeting other people and
become more cultured and I don't know I
took a bunch of mushrooms and had like a
really profound trip about like why you
shouldn't be a [ __ ] racist piece of
[ __ ] and me and my dad had words and
talked to him about it how I feel and
you should have dosed him should have
dosed him yeah some mushrooms and his
scrambled eggs yeah he would love that
he liked all that [ __ ] oh he did it and
he was still racist yeah I think that
that was just like how where he was how
he was raised you know didn't he didn't
his dad wasn't around and he hung around
like he was a delinquent kid you know
didn't didn't graduate high school he
just he was a painter and then he got it
he got a job at the city and it was a
good job and my mom worked in um
my mom worked in like merchandising like
out in grocery stores and convenience
stores like the end cap setups you know
stuff like that and yeah she went from
town to town doing that well yeah I mean
I think uh
that you're a racist stepdad came from
somewhere and he was raised with that as
well maybe he's better than what he was
raised in but I think like the cause of
all this hate is like a lack of
opportunity a lack of resources
and and resentment like it's a
resentment because of those things you
know people get resent just get results
and they don't have enough exactly yeah
the hate they're gonna hate that
situation it'd be weird if they didn't
they loved it then that's something
wrong with you as well yeah and I think
it's just economic I mean the whole uh
system that of Economics that we live in
was like you know based on you know like
people taking as much as they can and
it's better than feudalism
but it's not much better and I think
like the reason why there's so much hate
in the world is um a lack of money
flowing the way it should yeah and that
there's like economic inequality and I
think that's why there's hate that's
where there's racism that's why there's
like this obsession with like playing
with your own genitals because we don't
control anything in our economy the only
thing we can control is our genitals
like if we could have a store and we can
make a store that maybe like that would
take away the need to like change your
gender and be like the most creative
gender possible to get attention but we
don't control anything like all that
[ __ ] is controlled by Walmart or like
PepsiCo and like g g e and like since
our the the the tools of controlling our
environment and world is taken away from
us and we're just stuck in this like
what can we change like if we go out
like you have to have so much money to
buy any piece of land
and then to yeah like to make anything
it's just costs so much money like we
don't control anything the only thing we
can control is ourselves
uh so we change our genitals and all
that and uh we Growers at full and we're
like why don't we have enough and then
we get racist and I feel like if money
flowed instead of just being trapped up
top that it would be a way more loving
and beautiful Society it's all about
money yeah I think people would be more
focused I mean just be more focused on
living their lives if it wasn't as if
there wasn't a struggle to do so you
know if it wasn't surviving and they
were thriving you know it would
definitely everyone just seems a lot
happier when they're thriving you know
yeah
and there are like rich kids that become
addicts but they're living in a society
that has that kind of basement where
that is available to them and most
addicts are not rich children they're
poor people most homeless people are not
rich children they're people that were
struggling and then we have no
low-income housing we have no social
safety net or labor rights so we're
going to get a lot of people that fall
through the system and if you don't want
homeless people then you gotta get rid
of them
and you gotta have good labor rights and
stuff yeah
that's true
so uh yeah I mean what do you think
about watching porn from an early age
um
it was definitely I mean it definitely
had an effect on me like probably the
reason why I've been single for so long
you know has you just
you know you're just growing up seeing
all these different magazines and
basically it's the same white dude
having sex with all these different
girls in different magazines so I'm like
oh that's what a guy does he just goes
out and has sex you know like that's
what makes a man you know growing up as
I grew up
but I mean
like I've mellowed out a lot since then
like I don't even really watch porn like
anymore I mean when it's necessary you
know if I need to get one out you know
but that's about it and it's not like
I've I've never was like obsessed with
it to where I was like I had to watch it
all the time we're reading it like I
mean I never really did have access to
like internet porn until I was like 18
because we lived in the country and dial
up was barely out there and we had like
a family computer and an office room you
know and so when I moved out at 19 I
bought I bought a computer and I got
Wi-Fi hooked up to my apartment and I
was like the first time I actually like
had full-blown like access to the
internet it's like at a momentous time
in your life that was a great apartment
I loved that that my first apartment it
was cool it was just everywhere oh yeah
everywhere it's covered extra wallpaper
the walls were painted like I mean I
think I'm like that's bad but I think
that's in general like a lot of people
feel that way that a man needs to go out
and have a lot of sex
yeah I thought and you know for a long
time I thought that's what it was and
yeah I don't know just growing up age
experience heartache all the combination
of everything just life you know kind of
realize that it's really not all that
important you know it's really not that
big that you learned that it's not
important to like go out and try to [ __ ]
as many people as possible yeah
and it's better to have like a stable
loving it's a lot nicer and a lot more
mellow you know yeah but not as much
I mean even like even like the last
couple years when I was single just I
was single I wasn't I wasn't going out
and trying to get laid wasn't going out
partying like wasn't on my mind like you
had a couple hookups occasionally
throughout the year you know yeah a
couple little flings but I mean it
wasn't like a hard thing to do like even
living here in Austin like I mean this
is this girlfriend's like the first girl
that I've like hooked up with it's like
she's the closest one that lives in this
town you know she's playing Temple you
know she's yeah and she's an hour away
kind of thing like and just don't mess
around with it like it's difficult
working at the gym though sometimes
there are like a lot of good looking
girls at the gym and like I worked the
front desk so they just come up and talk
to me all the time and like they'll
linger at the desk and chat and it's
like just throwing it yeah I'm just like
yeah cool I know but if they really
wanted it they would have actually
pursue it it's like I guess if you're
single too then you would pursue it and
maybe you can meet in the middle but
yeah yeah I don't know maybe a lot of
them wouldn't have uh pursued you if
they knew that you were available maybe
they sense that you're sort of
unavailable and that you're safe and
that they can maybe not themselves
around them yeah and plus I'm the guy at
the gym and I see them five days a week
you know I come to work there I work
there yeah and it's their exposure
effect yeah totally I mean it's like and
plus you don't want to [ __ ] where you
eat when you're actually like you don't
have the trauma at the place where you
go get work you know it's risky because
yeah you could get fired it's not a good
move but yeah I mean it's obviously not
that big of a deterrent because people
do it all the time no they do some
people just don't give a [ __ ] yeah I
mean love is way more important than
some stupid job oh yeah yeah exactly
some front desk job at a joke man yeah
so unless it's a great job yeah it's not
the greatest job but I enjoy it it's
easy and yeah yeah and I get to a free
gym membership I'm at the gym five days
a week minimum and I'm working out every
day you know it's good it's nice you
just I'm up early which is a drag
sometimes you know got to go to bed a
little early on some days but I sleep
when I get off work I'll take care of
what I need to do take like a few hour
nap and then get up and go go out and do
comedy and then I'll come home and I'll
get like another it's a good life yeah
it work out I get I get my eight to ten
hours of sleep a day
yeah that's important yeah you got good
a good work schedule and do you work
like full time or
um yeah I work my work five days like
Monday through Friday and I'm working
I'm I'm technically a part-time employee
but I pick up all the I pick up shifts
and make I make full-time hours there
because people always need some time off
and like during the day it really
doesn't mess with anything I need to do
you know yeah other than the other day
when on Sunday I was like oh I'm working
late today you know it just happened to
be one of those days yeah but
so what do you think about socialism
socialism
which one's that what's the one where uh
labor rights less uh less money going to
the Super Rich more money going to
workers only spread it out yeah I'll get
you yeah my life my little brother
actually has his uh his his degree in
socialism
um
what not socialism but social work not
social work
I'm sorry I'm still a little stoned from
earlier
um it is a sociology oh yeah that's not
socialism now that's just a study of
different uh cultures and stuff okay
um I mean in theory it seems nice and I
would love it I'd love to be taken care
of have more money coming in and being
able to live freely like that sounds
great and everything but at the same
time I also I like the I like the I'd
kind of like the struggle sometimes I'm
enjoying the struggle right now I mean
but like what's the amount of struggle
will you be
willing to put up with versus how much
is being stolen from you like yeah sure
you could make do with what you have now
but how much do you actually deserve
yeah like we are producing more than
ever before and we still have the same
number of
same amount of income
I just think like uh yeah it's great
that we have enough now but the amount
that's being stolen from us is like
unconscionable yeah they get a lot
yeah like taxes and everything no not
taxes uh like corporate oh uh
malfeasance and lack of Labor rights
lack of unions
you think the problem is the government
the problem's always been the government
but who controls the government uh it's
like isn't it like there's I don't know
some rich guy probably yeah then why
blame the government why not blame the
rich guy
I mean
because yeah I don't know I don't have a
good answer for that I mean of course
you blame the rich guy yeah I mean but I
mean who knows who that guy is you don't
have access to him he's not on any lists
you know yeah someone you've never met
like the Forbes list yeah like someone
you've never heard of you know yeah just
so like politics like you don't really
care about it I don't really mess with I
don't really mess with the dude it just
kind of bums me out like just like then
turn on the news and it's always like
country's negative news on CNN you know
yeah like so I mean I'm yeah I stopped
watching the news and getting into all
that like I'm a terrible American I
don't vote I don't pay any of that I
just yeah just live my life and just go
about my business going with the flow
and my parents like try and talk about
it with me and I'm like I don't know who
you're talking about and they kind of
get frustrated sometimes but like my dad
will be like telling me about like Trump
or Pelosi and I'm like okay like what'd
they do now I guess you know or
yeah it's a lot of concern too yeah but
maybe that's just what are you concerned
about the Honeys at the gym no I'm just
concerned with
just concerned with being happy trying
to make myself happy and provide for
myself and be a provider and a good
enough provider that I could maybe like
have a family one day if I wanted that
but or also just do the things I want to
do but I also want to do something that
makes me happy so that's why I'm
pursuing comedy and I'm concerned with
getting on shows and doing the best of
my ability and
I mean that's my main concern right now
I mean it might be that might be selfish
one like because it's just I'm pretty
self-concerned at the moment you know
about what I'm doing yeah you know I
mean I was pretty set up back in
California before I moved out here I
could have taken over the family
business had a cushy life and I made a
decision to
right but that's not fun right like yeah
it's not no one wants to just be like oh
I made it through life yeah comfortably
and happily exactly so like I'm
concerned with like dealing with the
struggle for like being on my own for
the first time in my life you know
without the safety net of the family
business or having money yeah I had to
go out there and produce my own trying
to make something more than just like a
normal like oh like in the 1400s you
mowed all the Lawns and got a good crop
and congratulations like No One's Gonna
remember that guy but like Leonardo da
Vinci or like
Michelangelo it's like people remember
him Legacy absolutely I mean yeah you
want to make a Mark I feel like yeah I
mean you're making a mark right now
you're you're pins on the paper right
now dude this is how big is the mark
gonna be you know and just make it as
big as possible I feel like I'm in a
good place now I'm not like I'm ready to
make a mark but I feel like right now
I'm just like you know lying in the
shadows trying to figure out where to go
no absolutely because I don't want to
like make a big stink and just come out
as a communist right now and then blow
my load and oh no yeah absolutely
you're still just like I said you're
you're sitting there and you're just
slowly making that Mark you're figuring
out where you want the Shadows mine in
the shadows in front of all those people
it's fun it's a good time yeah I'm just
trying to figure out because I don't
want to do like this podcast like it's
fun and I get to practice and get better
at it so that's why I do it but yeah I
don't want to like
I don't want this to be my main thing
that people know you for yeah this isn't
like the end yeah I mean it's kind of
like with now today's like in like
today's worlds like you're a comedian
gotta have a podcast now you know like
and that's like do you really want to be
doing that because I mean not I do I
mean I get a lot from it yeah yeah I
mean I I enjoyed mine that I do I love
that it's a cliche yeah oh you have a
podcast everyone has a podcast yeah good
everyone should have a podcast yeah and
like that gives me the cover to be like
yeah I'm a comedian with a podcast but
what I'm actually doing is like therapy
and like no absolutely this is great
yeah for free with friends you know
people you're interested in having
conversations with you're learning you
know it's awesome it's fun yeah it's
like what your idea of like only
thinking about yourself and not worrying
about politics
it's like
I worry about myself by Boring people by
talking about politics and how I hate
women
is that the theme for like every episode
yeah okay it's like we should take care
of the homeless your podcast the He-Man
Woman Haters Club with Hans Kim is that
the name of it women haters communist
women haters.com
dot com ibi.org
um you should make it a DOT org what's
uh what's the difference just
organization.org.gov dot biz
um yeah so how old are you
I'm 35. okay
that's great because I'm used to talking
with people that are younger than me
and you grew up with Hustler magazines
yeah
but yeah when I was in Middle School you
just like take a few of them to school
and sell them to the like all my friends
and stuff
make some money I need a new skateboard
or something just take one in Excel to a
kid at school let me see if the audio is
working
uh can you read that I don't have my
glasses uh I'll drop like I'll drop a
like though uh Han smells his Han smells
his farts Mr Hans Kim Senior Kim in the
office anything about the sound
uh no one's saying anything about the
sound at all okay yeah what's up guys
okay I think that's it oh yeah cool
sounds working yeah they're my PA
they're my they're your soundboard yeah
Engineers yeah nice awesome I'm thinking
of having this be over here yeah by the
way it's not like it looks like
okay we're plugged right in
that's it actually it is a pretty cool
view like the the vantage point at the
middle lines yeah what uh what are you
doing a podcast you do a podcast right I
do
um me and my roommate we have a podcast
that um we just started putting on
YouTube it's called Uh playing [ __ ]
with Matt and Nick and it's spelled pzy
and it's like a more of a therapeutic
podcast kind of like this Matt and Nick
yeah with Matt and Nick Matt Amos I
don't know if you've met him yet no I
don't think so um he's a buddy of mine
that I moved out here with um but was
more of like a therapeutic podcast like
how we do it we're just two comedians
that talk to each other and talk about
our weeks and it's called playing [ __ ]
because like we have this saying that we
like it's like if you play [ __ ] you're
gonna get [ __ ] so don't play [ __ ] go
out there and do your [ __ ] and handle
your business and be the best you can be
and then we just talk about like what
happened to us in that one does that
mean don't you want to get [ __ ] if you
play if you are a [ __ ] or if you play
like a [ __ ] do you I mean do you want
to get like do you want to get [ __ ] or
do you want to like rock the situation
it's like not [ __ ] in the having sex
sense like you want to get like oh man
I'm screwed over yeah you don't want to
get screwed you don't want to like lose
out on you don't want to be [ __ ] like
that yeah you know you got to be strong
and confident all the time or not like
just work on it and like have set goals
and we just discuss what we did that
week or and then we talk about like how
if we had goals for like a set or if we
talk about or like previous sets at
different shows and she's a comedian
yeah awesome
um he doesn't come out much but he is a
comedian he's been going to a lot of
open mics but he's funny to himself he's
himself correct he's pretty funny I'm
sure yeah I was just kidding because he
doesn't go out yeah he doesn't go he's
just like really introverted yeah he's
he's a comedian it's really weird yeah
and he has this whole theory about how
comedy is like an introverted thing
because it's like you're the only one on
stage and you're talking and yeah it's
your ideas yeah exactly people who need
other people are probably aren't gonna
be good at it because they need that
counter
counter punch to
to fight back against yeah
I mean it takes all types at some point
you have to provide your own
intellectual backing for what you're
saying you can't just rely on other
people and making fun of them yeah you
have to make sure everything stands up
and holds up yeah you gotta have your
own thoughts yeah
but I have that so we have that podcast
playing [ __ ] and then
um then I have the drinking coffee with
Nick uh podcast you know it's more of
like an anti-podcast or a little talk
show yeah and yeah and I do those two
things and those brought me a lot of fun
and I mean [ __ ] when I first moved out
here drinking coffee when Nick started
just because I was meeting a bunch of
people and seeing everyone putting Clips
out and content and I didn't have any of
that so I was like well I don't I'm
brand new to the scene and like I need
to be invisible at least so it started
off with just me sitting in front of the
window saying oh hello welcome to drink
and coffee I'd look out the window and
say something like the first one it was
during the freeze and so the window was
all Frozen and I was just like oh it
looks chilly outside and I took a sip
and did the slurp and I was like thanks
for stopping by and then I did one more
and then a comic was like hey could I do
you ever want to do like yes can I be a
guest on that and who was that comeback
is Ben Howard oh nice yeah Ben Howard
came up to me he was like he's like do
you ever are you gonna do guests or
anything exactly like me yeah he's like
and I was like yeah sure come over and
then we did it and then after his
um I did one with Matt my roommate and
then people started really liking him
and asking hey can I come on hey you
were here for the freeze uh I was here I
was not the not the heavy yeah you're
freezed for the winter I was here for
the winner with that when I say the
freeze it was like Frozen for like four
days you know you can't say the freeze
the freeze well it just meant like okay
so it was frozen freeze yeah not the
free I wasn't here for that now I heard
about that yeah I'm glad I missed it I'm
gonna miss it too like people talking
about their power being out and
everything yeah we didn't have any power
outages like at my apartment so I was
happy yeah you shouldn't have fragile
infrastructure should get your [ __ ]
together a little bit yeah
but yeah so I mean that's what kind of
got me into like having a podcast was
just like doing it with just out of
necessity yeah but then that's why I did
the drinking coffee one and then me and
Matt we just have we just sit there and
talk about [ __ ] and it's fun and Phil I
always feel good afterwards like like
you said therapeutic yeah yeah it's like
we have our own radio shows like back in
the day when we were growing up it'd be
like oh man it would be awesome if we
had a radio show and now we can have one
and no yeah now we actually do find out
how hard it actually is yeah but yeah I
mean would you play music on yours or
um you could
I know Matt would want to because like
would you start talking about stuff and
he'll bring up like he'll bring he he's
a he likes to play guitar and he's
really into metal so he'll bring up like
music references and like I know there's
times in the podcast where he would be
like oh and like you can see how he how
he did this in this song you know and
he'd bring it up but I mean I'm just I'm
just gonna sit there and chat and Matt
asked me questions I ask him questions
and we just [ __ ] and have a good
time and I don't even know how many I
mean there's a handful of people that
watch it like probably about this many
you know yeah pick on the views but a
handful a handful you know yes I picked
five people up with your hand yeah well
one at a time
that's hard to do man you have been
working out at your gym I've been
working out
what do you think about yoga pants
they're the best I know that's so crazy
they're so good they're like the
greatest invention like the world is
really a good place yeah it it yeah it's
it's nice yeah I mean people want to
show off their butts they do and we
should let them and they do we do yeah I
mean we let them here in Austin we let
them show off their chest too but they
don't they don't want they don't take
advantage of that one's a little too far
I mean too far I mean they passed the
law you know yeah I mean like nobody
wants to be the first one yeah it's true
unless you have an amazing chest yeah
you're flaunting it for now for you just
like oh yeah we're doing it but if
you're the only one doing it you're
gonna attract a lot of negative
attention a lot of yeah a lot of
unwanted attention yeah
negative would be on the perspective but
yeah unwanted for sure well yeah I've
seen those videos where the women like
the the women like paint have their
pants painted on and they go walk down
like the streets of New York yeah
they're just walking in like they have
like jeans painted on them but they're
just wearing no pants yeah that's why I
always make sure that it's an actual
pants because you're up there I don't
want to be like oh
I'm in the video I totally didn't
realize she was naked I could have got a
ass full of an eye full of ass an eye
full of ass yeah not a asphalt eyes
because you wouldn't want that at all
my ass is full of eyes a lot of eyes on
my ass what uh I mean I've been uh
trying to like curtail my uh staring
like I don't want to be too scary
because it is really easy just to get
lost in the oh 100 yeah my uh like I
remember count to three one two three
cool
Mississippi too Mississippi yeah because
three seconds can be a long three
seconds that's when you get caught so
you go and go one two three and then one
two three yeah
I'm glad the music guy isn't uh doing
that
he keeps a better beat maybe just do two
seconds One Mississippi two Mississippi
okay do two seconds then My Philosophy
on Staring at women is to not make it
weird if I eventually do end up talking
to her yeah like as long as it's like oh
hey what's up I mean all you can do is I
mean worse I mean they say what are you
looking at oh I'm sorry it was just I
was being captivated by her beauty yeah
oh that's not you going up to them and
being like hey baby what's up you know
you got caught staring she questioned
you you and you went up to it but an
implied way
I mean all this I mean she could but
take it to her anyway still especially
in America they hate that [ __ ] yeah
they're like how dare you yeah I know I
dressed up I don't want to look pretty
but this is meant for
uh my economic gain and you're just
taking it from me even though it cost me
nothing with all the with all the white
people appropriation that's gone on in
our country
and then also the combination of that
person being one of those people that
don't want you staring at them why
haven't they started wearing burkas
exactly that's what we're heading
towards yeah that's what happens when
you start like policing women or women
are like I don't want people to stare at
me this is all for me yeah my beauty is
not for the society that I hate like if
women love the society that they're in
that I feel like they would be more
beautiful but then you get these liberal
people that like cut their hair short
and don't wear makeup and wear like
shitty clothes because they don't like
the society and they don't want to make
it a more beautiful place yeah
so if we had like a decent Society I
think there'd be a lot more hot people
around
when we legalize abortion and glass
abortion you know the free healthcare
you know people can take care of
themselves easier it gives them more
desire to take care of themselves you
know yeah because I mean if you're in a
situation they feel cared for yeah they
feel cared for they're going to care for
themselves and others I like how we keep
circling back to it
yeah
yeah what do you think you think I'm uh
gloomy and misogynistic
I mean
not right now
you're not concerned by anything I'm not
concerned with you
you don't think I'm a danger you could
be a danger I could see I could see it
running a little wild you know just
being like you said you want to make
that uh you want to change that about it
just be a little more open and it'll
take some time but you just make the
conscious decision and just be like I'm
gonna be a little like just more
accepting maybe you know
you know don't rain well you can only be
so accepting for so long before you're
like this isn't working out these people
are [ __ ] that's true that's kind of
where I'm at well I mean you just just
pick who you want to be around you know
like you can still be that same person
but you don't have to stay in the same
circle of people I uh I mean eventually
you have to be around some circular
people that's what I'm saying but you've
got to pick that's your decision to pick
who you'd want to be around but you
can't always pick not especially if
you're like working at an office or like
you're in a city yeah but I get that but
you don't have to make them part of your
personal circle like that's your work
Circle it's just like yeah I just don't
uh I I feel like all people are shitty
like in general like there's like a pawl
of shittiness over our city and yeah
country yeah everyone can be and then
I'm like most I have like a port open
for women and then that's where all the
hate and negativity comes in because if
a dude is shitty to me I'm just like
whatever yeah I don't really give a [ __ ]
but it bothers you women yeah and yeah
I'm sure men are way worse if I was
trying to [ __ ] them yeah I bet it's not
because like gay guys seem pretty happy
yeah those seem pretty nice but I mean
so it really bothers you like the women
being shitty affects me more but that
doesn't necessarily mean they're
shittier than men I just notice they're
[ __ ] us more okay
yeah maybe it's just because you do
because you just like because you're not
you're not that interested in another
man you know yeah I don't need as much
from them yeah for a woman I want to
take everything I want to take
everything
so you've been doing a lot of traveling
lately what's been your favorite place
to go to
like as I've recently gone in like your
travels like the show wise not not
necessarily because of like the show but
like the cities you were in did you do
any like a cool thing I didn't really do
any cool exploring I just like you know
hang out with this crew of people in
different cities okay it's like oh my
friends in this situation in that
situation I think it was Chicago
that I had a really cool experience in
we had a hotel that went up and you had
to go across and then go up on another
hotel oh another elevator yeah and then
we had I remember the lobby very vividly
for some reason but that's like I think
it was Chicago yeah I think it was but
yeah it was a cool experience I got to
say in some really nice hotels
some of the best hotels which is really
cool you know see how people that are
actually taking care of feel
um and yeah it's uh it's cool the
elevator had a layover
they're connecting elevator connecting
elevator I think uh I think in Vegas I
had to do that in one of no maybe not no
in San Francisco I think I had to do
that take another elevator to get out
and walk down the hall to the other do
you like traveling
it's fun I like it I don't mind depends
on what the context is travel is so
vague you can travel to get murdered or
yeah well I like flying it's fun the
airports are cool
um I mean they're not the best but I
mean I haven't done it too much in my
life so I mean I enjoy being on an
airplane it's not that I ended up just I
always end up sleeping the whole time
anyway
um so I never really sit there and
experienced like the the airplane but I
like going to new places like going and
checking out like in state parks and
some going to like real places of like
just being outdoors is nice
um I like traveling and going to Big
like music festivals with my friends we
would do that like
a lot like back home and stuff like that
like every time there's music for a
candy Music Festival would happen we'd
just get tickets and go like travel two
three hours you're a big Music Festival
guy right I used to be I used to be
really into going to like house and what
is it that you like about it the chicks
their boobs chicks they're taming their
boobs is always nice but I mean like the
music is good I enjoy it I enjoy like
dance being able to dance and dance sit
around dance with my friends in a place
where I don't feel like sit around and
dance with your friends you know what I
mean go and be around all my chill chill
dancing dudes do drugs and have a good
time you know like isn't it weird to
like think about dancing though
to think let's go dance somewhere you
know I don't know I I don't think it's
all that weird I think it's fun to be
like what are you guys doing oh we're
going dancing you know like really I'm
going to see this DJ that I like I got
this move that I want to try I think you
guys are gonna like it oh yeah you got
any special dance moves you got any
what's your go-to that one all right so
I always do like this that's it you know
yeah that's my move you like to flare
the elbows elbow flare you know maybe
take a step here step there and just up
around step around you know just goof
off that's the one thing about going to
like those best music festivals everyone
there is [ __ ] up on drugs no one's
looking at you you can act as silly and
goofy as you want and no one cares and
you're just having a good time and it's
very humid it's very Primal yeah to like
gather around the campfire and move
around yeah absolutely yeah you ever
gone to any music festivals or any like
yeah you went to the one in Bumbershoot
in Seattle
um but yeah it's I haven't really gone
out and sought it out I know I would
enjoy it but it's sort of weird for me
to be like let's choose to be happy
that's not in my Arsenal oh [ __ ] well
maybe next time a good DJ comes around
I'll get to get us tickets and we'll go
that'd be awesome yeah I'd love to
partake in there not a tribal dance of
our people and just go dance around be
goofy have some drinks and talk to
people and if if you do talk to them and
if not that's the cool thing is that you
can go and make friends and I've met I
still have a lot of good friends that I
stay in touch with that live all over
the country from just going to different
music festivals and then them just
meeting them and they're like oh we're
from Denver or we're from Seattle like
you know so I have a good friend
actually one of them was just in town
for his bachelor party here in Austin I
wouldn't have met up with them you know
and it was weird because we met in
California and they're from Seattle you
know yeah so those guys are meeting
people in the right context yeah it's
like fuel their injured that yeah
they're interested and they're they're
in a good mood and like you said it's
they're spreading love because we're
surrounded by a bunch of love and
everyone's having a good time no one's
fighting there's no homeless people you
only get the best I mean technically
they're all we're all homeless there
because we're in we're camping in tents
you know homeless things
I know what you're saying I was just
making a joke right yeah because you
guys are nomads it's like very Primal
yeah that's beautiful it's a good time
what's what's your what's your uh what's
your like ideal Music Festival
um my ideal I don't know I was my my
favorite one is my favorite one so far
has been Dirty Bird camp out I've never
heard of it that's so cool that the best
one is like a hidden one yeah it's uh by
a record labor record label called Dirty
Bird
um and they put it on they've been
putting it on for I think now seven
years I went to the first five of them
but I didn't go to like the last two
um and just it was out out in California
they do they made another one for the
East Coast called camp in and they they
rent out like this this big hotel and
they told they throw like the party and
the festival all weekend in that inside
that hotel
which is pretty cool so it's just
dancing and socializing and drugs yeah
pretty much that's cool and then all my
friends back home are DJs and music
producers so they're like I'm always
like I was all never in that world yeah
it was just always in that world because
they're I like the music one and then
that that's what they do and they book
shows and so it was fun like they'd big
DJs would come in or DJs would come into
town or if we'd be at an event with
doing everything
um I would actually like get to know
like the actual artists themselves
because like they're like oh eventually
it comes down the line because you make
the rounds talking to people like oh
what are you doing like Oh I'm a
comedian you know it's like something
different for them because everyone's
talking music with them and then I think
they're more drawn to like hanging out
and talking to me because it's happened
quite a bit you know yeah it's like that
comic and musician connection you think
like uh your personality has been shaped
by these music festivals
to be more chill and be ready to talk to
people and socialize in a music festival
setting um
I think it I mean it couldn't it
couldn't hurt you know I mean I feel
comfortable there when I'm there and
enjoying myself I'm dressed goofy as as
well and just or maybe just in shorts or
like just maybe no shirt or just hanging
out [ __ ] you're wild yeah you know just
sounds like a time you see the good side
of people you like access the positive
side and you're like oh in a grocery
store oh let me you know this side of
them exists as well they're just not
showing it yeah you know I mean I'm
giving people the benefit of the doubt
until they prove me wrong and then once
you prove me wrong then it's just then
that is death and destruction I mean
then it's just like you're cut off yeah
you know I mean the I don't care like
I'm I'm very easy going but I mean like
you you betray or [ __ ] someone over you
know that's why am I going to stress
about you anymore yeah just bye
yeah just kind of come on clean your
hands of it you know so many people you
can pick and choose and have like
editorial control
that's what you need to do you just need
to make sure I am doing that I know
that's good yeah why are you telling me
that I have to do that when I'm already
doing that I'm just saying you're
talking about why how you seeing the
negative earlier so I mean that's kind
of like how I do it that's how I do well
you said that there's like a lot of
haters and it's just because like
they're around other haters yeah
the surround yourself around positive
experiences like you have been and
continue to do that and your circle will
probably get bigger and or maybe not
bigger but just more quality thank you
yeah
try to find uh people I get along with
um but yeah I mean
I uh
I don't like some people I think some
people are not very uh
conducive I think they're toxic and then
cut them out of my life
um what do you think about slavery you
think that we should learn how to
empathize with slave owners so that we
can better understand and have empathy
and love for
people that are hateful so that we can
come together as one
I mean that's how that theoretically
that's how you're supposed to
over conquer that you know you
beat hate with love
but you can't I mean it's a hard
situation especially I'm bringing up
slavery like that's terrible
I'm owning another person yeah I mean
what makes what gives you what gives
them the right to think they can own
another human sentient being you know
what I mean yeah hierarchy because they
can they have power and they want to use
it yeah and unfortunately I mean that's
still very prevalent today you know yeah
I mean if you have
steadily improving slavery and then you
get to a point where it's like
technically it's not slavery but you are
getting paid as little as possible to do
as much work as possible then it's like
yeah I mean technically it's not slavery
but it's still not good we should try to
move more away and up I get that but
when it comes down to it they have the
decision to walk away if you're talking
about jobs like they have decisions but
do they do they really have decisions if
you take away as much as possible like
you don't give them any health care or
food and then you like in the hood
there's a McDonald's you could work
there or you could starve it's not
really a choice yeah that's true but I
mean
there's a will there's a white man I
mean you can well what Society has the
most social mobility and is that our
country or do we not have very good
social Mobility
it's it's difficult to say because I
mean
we have for all the bad stuff there are
some good stuff and for all the good
stuff there's a lot of bad stuff yeah
you just got to make sure that it
doesn't fall into a mixture of too much
bad yeah too little good yeah that's why
you just gotta push the positivity and
the love you know as me when every
opportunity and fight for it when we'll
find defeat the Confederates and get rid
of slavery yeah
um so what do you think about Trump
I think he's hilarious he's a funny dude
like so we should elect him again
because you love positivity and humor
well positivity and humor so that's why
we should vote for him
um honestly
my life wasn't that bad when Troublesome
president I mean I didn't vote for him
well how much better could your life
have been under the leadership and warm
embrace of Hillary Rodham Clinton oh I
don't I don't know I mean I feel like
they you know they created covid to shut
the world down so they could get rid of
trump they had to shut the world down to
get rid of them you know and he was and
you know every every time you turn on
social media or get on social media I
should say and you just see a funny clip
of him doing something wild like what
what's the funniest thing that he's done
like the whole ground by the [ __ ] just
like calling people funny it was
hilarious just him talking like that
because you're a guy I'm a guy I could
find you way better close it's the
context that's funny like huh then let's
select [ __ ] Ron Jeremy and he'll say
way more [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah he would he
would say [ __ ] up [ __ ] I'm not saying
I want him to be president just because
of [ __ ] up [ __ ] I don't even
necessarily want him to be president but
I'm just saying
I don't even believe the president has
all that much power I think the
government's just already picked and ran
and from above and it's just a facade
you know I mean I get it because like
you don't really have any say in it I
mean we don't really have any say in it
so you might as well find the joy and
humor in it but it's like if you're
looking at it objectively and like sort
of like pretending like you have power
and then trying to like gameplay an
armchair quarterback it's like not the
ideal situation for this country or the
world
but I mean yeah I mean if you enjoy it
then I guess like yeah just have a good
time yeah
uh what do you think about transgender
people they exist
do you think that maybe there's more
than that exists than really that are
suffering from that medical condition
yeah I was in I was thinking about that
earlier I was like how pissed do you
think like a hermaphrodite like a fully
born person with two with belgians how
do you think they feel about this like
yeah every teenager that's a little sad
yeah what is it you have the joke you
have the joke where it's like um
Millennials Millennials about like oh
I'm a I'm like a five so I'm gonna
change my hair and turn it yeah and yeah
I mean turn my hair blue and become a
different gender yeah yeah I like that
joke it makes me laugh it's because it's
so mean it's so weird
it's like yeah I mean nobody wants to
say it but yeah that's like a large
portion of people yeah or teenagers that
are just like I they think it's the
thing to do be hot yeah they think it's
something to do or they yeah they want
something about them because they don't
that's also that could be a thing that's
like you know they don't have any like
real identity
like that defines who they are what
they're into and it's unfortunately some
people just feel do have that have that
ability or have that identity crisis and
other people are just doing it for
attention you know it's they're all sad
because like there's like kids that have
it yeah and then they're like uh I
always felt like a boy or a girl and
then like yeah and then like now there's
like laws in Texas like you can be
arrested for child abuse
if you do that [ __ ]
um well I mean a teenager like someone
without a fully fun formed like frontal
lobe shouldn't be making that decision
at any point before that you know like
yeah and if you are a four and you want
to change your gender because you're not
hot then fine you should be allowed to
yeah you should be allowed to but I mean
you shouldn't they should be able to do
it after like a certain point you know
like you should but then their body is
already formed like if you get it at
puberty maybe you could really change it
up but yeah I mean well I understand
that but I mean like let's say it's just
like me as a exactly how I am right now
I was just like I think I'm a woman now
like I've had to you know like
and that that's like set that's like 13
year old me thinking that but there's no
like real medical condition for that
like I don't know it's a touchy subject
you know I've never actually I mean I'm
I've never like met anybody that's uh
been just like oh I just did it because
you know yeah well no one would say that
yeah but there's plenty of examples of
people that are just like losers and now
they're like I have a thing now I'm
interesting finally that's true but yeah
I mean I think uh everyone needs to be
physically something yeah instead of
intellectually like why don't you work
on your brain and make something of
yourself besides just changing your
gender because that's like the least
interesting thing you could do I don't
give a [ __ ] yeah like if you want to
dress like a lady dress like a lady and
someone asks you why I do that be like
because I feel like this you know I mean
yeah and then actually have something to
contribute besides just the fact that
you're willing to take a risk and get a
surgery
yeah we don't value the right things in
people I think yeah Society doesn't yeah
but I think like the main goal of
education and jobs and cubicle work is
to create stability like just keep
everything the same don't question don't
try to change anything no absolutely
it's definitely a um
it's definitely a uh a problem our
education system's [ __ ] we do we go we
adopted our education system from the
prussians and there really yeah I did so
I did a paper on it and in my philosophy
class like in the last years of college
and it made me like really regret the
previous three and a half years in
college I know like because it's
basically we developed um we adopted the
system because Prussia had a system that
basically bred followers that would not
um would not Retreat or disobey like
their generals you know because they had
a war they were they had a war one year
where they like everyone retreated and
they lost so then they developed this
system and like their boot camps and
stuff to like basically create followers
yeah yes man like just listen people
were like that looks like a good and
then more of that and then the American
public system adopted that system and
put it into schools because they that
was like the height of the Industrial
Revolution because they needed people
that were educated enough to be able to
work in a factory but also be keep them
dumb enough to be happy working in a
factory you know yeah like you said to
make that stability yeah that's how and
that's that's what our current education
system is based off of and it's like
that's why our anger is put into useless
directions like Flat Earth yeah or you
know how dumb is that
it makes sense though I get where a lot
of that is coming from because it's like
if the world is gonna let you grow up in
food and secure household and your
mother is going to be single and you're
dead they're gonna lock your dad up for
your whole life then why wouldn't they
lie to you about all these other things
that's true I mean my little brother who
he likes him he likes to talk about all
that stuff and he shows me like the U.N
map and stuff all the times like the U.N
flag is like this is just a map this is
what the world really looks like you
know and then like my favorite new one
that I would like it's not that I
believe it but I would love it to be
real is like how Antarctica is like
basically an actual wall around us and
then the rest of the world that's like
beyond that and like you can't go see it
or anything like that like if any of
those were to be true I would hope it
would be that one just because I think
that would just be mind-blowing you know
yeah
like oh my God we've been lived like if
something like that happened and it was
like legitimately proved but at the same
time yeah well to some people it is like
that like the fact that their dad was
locked up or for no reason for marijuana
it's like the ice wall all that's like
pretty much what you did to them so it
makes sense that their brain would be
that broken
I mean because you shook up their world
yeah I mean I feel like
yeah I mean that does suck but I was
just saying I was I was talking more
about the context of one of those
conspiracies were actually like 100 true
and like if we got to find out it was
true you know yeah I think we're
I don't know
but yeah I mean that's like that's a
that's a shitty situation though for
them as well being inside that
metaphoric ice wall yeah
um
I think we should treat people better
but that's not our goal our goal is to
preserve the wealth of the people that
run our world and we just give them the
power we're like whatever that's theirs
this is the way it is don't change it up
I'm fine I get enough
and it's like it could be so much better
and we're just happy with not horrible
at least it's not terrible but it could
be great
yeah it could be great
but uh yeah I mean what do you uh what
do you what is on your mind recently any
controversial subjects that you've been
dealing with no um not controversial
subjects really uh I've been
like I've just been
focusing just my nose to the grindstone
really just been trying to grind it out
and how do you come up with jokes
um like I'll get stoned and maybe go for
a walk and like think of stuff or like
maybe I'll see something and like I'll
just write you know something funny will
pop into my head I'll write it down I
like to do some free riding where it's
like this could be like the sidewalks
here suck we could maybe improve our
infrastructure
just a bunch of like infrastructure
jokes yeah yeah
um that's how I came out with the
homeless one you know walking down the
street and uh seeing the homeless people
coming homeless jokes and where do you
what neighborhood do you live um I live
um I live in down South Congress uh like
William Cannon like not too far from
where you used to live oh okay like
right there's homeless people all the
way down there uh sometimes wow yeah I
mean sometimes but also like getting
stoned here in downtown and walking you
know like I call migratory homeless
people yeah
um I do that I'll do free writing and
just get a bunch of junk out yeah and
then I do that and then um like walking
is good A lot of people a lot of famous
writers and artists walk yeah I'd enjoy
it I liked sometimes I'm when I'm
driving a lot of times when I'm driving
if for some reason it feels like because
I'll be like not listening to the radio
and just kind of doing like going where
I'm going and just thinking so some
stuff will come up like that so then I
just grab my phone and just talk into it
real quick you know yeah
um but the free writing helps out a lot
especially just getting drunk out you
know yeah I'll sit there and like write
like I'm just writing because it
practices you practice getting what's in
here out here so even if you don't get
anything out during the free writing
after the free writing you're better at
converting thoughts into words no
absolutely yeah and that's been really
beneficial and honestly I've been uh
haven't been writing as much as I should
still a couple times a week you know but
not like every day
um and I just been kind of trying to get
more comfortable being myself phone
stage instead of like that character
that the the deadpan like dry guy trying
to be a little just more have more fun
interact with the audience a little bit
trapped in the yeah you know and I mean
it wasn't bringing me it used to bring
me a lot of joy to do that you know like
to go up there and Crush like that and
it was just it hasn't been as fun doing
it and
that was something I was talking with
Matt about on our podcast and so I did
it started doing it about a month ago
and like really just trying to like well
you don't want to force it either right
no no no not not like forcing it but
just going up and being like all right
well I'm not gonna not gonna be the dead
man I'm gonna go up I'm gonna smile I'm
gonna have a good time you know like
yeah I'm gonna enjoy myself on stage and
then if you choose to be deadpan then
it's a decision made out of power
instead of weakness yeah you know
and so what do you think about Elon Musk
Elon Musk he just had some babies didn't
he yeah it's like 11 babies I know he
has 11 but he just had some recent ones
okay I believe I think that's the last
thing I heard about him in the news
that's the good thing about being a man
she can have so many babies back to back
so you can have multiple babies at the
same time if you time it right having a
baby as a man it's easy yeah
you just you just show up
that's it it's so crazy
so unfair pretty much I'd show up and
you'll be a dad yeah just have to exist
yeah I mean I think Elon Musk is uh
decent he is he could be so much worse
but ideally you'd have
500 000 Elon musks
with that money spread out instead of
just one inventor and we have to rely on
him hopefully he does the right thing
makes the right decisions do you think
he'll do the right thing or do you think
he'll become like um
I think it's a Superman villain I think
it's impossible for him to do the the
right thing I think he'll do the best he
can because he's a you know decently
intelligent person who has is a decent
moral compass yeah
um but I think he is set up to fail like
no one can handle that kind of
responsibility yeah it's a lot yeah
what do you think about uh
I forget
um yeah
what uh what are you gonna do today
tonight I'm just gonna hang out probably
just work on some stuff I'm gonna
probably do some studying and we can
Janna get certified as a personal
trainer so I make more money at the gym
and just make it a little easier to to
live a bit you know what is the is the
certification process for being a
personal trainer [ __ ] or is it
actually I mean it's useful it's useful
it's good information I mean there's
there's there are I'm learning some
stuff as well as like some of the stuff
I already know so I'm just taking just
reading the courses online and just I'll
take the test and then like what's
something that you learned
and you just I'm just like getting
um learning like just they've been like
learning like my cardiovascular system
like learning about just just learning
all the different effects or things
about it has made me realize I need to
work on my cardiovascular health like so
I'm gonna start and doing starting to do
cardio and do stuff like that you know
just learning the vocabulary is a little
differently because you know you call it
like your but you call it like your
bicep or your calf muscle or like your
back and it's like your lats and your
traps and all that it's just all the
different terminology so you know what
you're learning with more yeah learning
how to spot imbalances in people's form
and things like that like to be like
that way you know how to correct it and
stuff yeah I just don't trust the
education system that we have and it
seems like a lot of our certification
processes are built on the back of like
oh it's like a test I mean yeah yeah I
mean that's basically what it is yeah
but I mean it's useful information and
yeah I mean it can be but is it like
retained and is it updated and is it
really like because knowledge is so so
fluid like yeah you know like a lot of
especially with exercise and diet like
people have new theories and all the
time yeah you gotta say schools of
thoughts
yeah but yeah I mean I think that the
process of certification can be useful I
just don't know yeah I mean if it is
it's just it's a it's an online course
that you read and you take a test they
have videos and structures but I mean
I'm learning do you trust our systems of
government what did you think about
covid and our response to it versus
other countries responses
I mean I just think covered was a little
blown out of proportion personally like
it was the flu
but if we didn't take it seriously in
the beginning when it was way more
deadly than it was now
then do you think that maybe it could
have gotten way worse it could have
maybe possibly like the hospitals were
overcrowded I mean yeah but a lot of I
feel like a lot of that was panicked I
mean there's just people with fevers
going to the hospital that had covered
that like barely had any symptoms but
they had coveted like I got covered and
if this was nothing I know but you
probably got it a little later on when
it was I got it early oh really yeah I
got like the first within like that
first like
couple months but like if you go to a
hospital and you see like people dying
and people in ventilators and I mean
that sucks but a lot of those people got
from from what I was told and heard like
a lot of people that died from the
ventilators because they went on the
ventilator they know right but the fact
that they had to go on a ventilator
means that they would have died even
without a ventilator yeah
like I'm sure it was inconvenient but
like
yeah but the purpose of a society isn't
to make sure that you can go to TGI
Fridays every day it's like to preserve
the human race and if we just let a
disease spread throughout our species
like it's not a very sustainable
solution no I understand that but I mean
there was I mean the how did how I mean
the flu kills people all the like every
year you know I mean it's part like
death is part of life like right but
like it killed way more people than the
flu
yeah
or did they just die from the flu and
they called it covid
well why would they die more from the
flu now
I'm just saying I mean flu case isn't
like dropped off completely yeah what
happened that's good yeah well yeah we
cared we cured the flu by I think like
the way to come to that decision to come
out of lockdown and isn't like I think
we did it in the most contentious way
possible yeah we're just like I want to
go out now I don't think that's like the
best way to make decisions no I mean
that's not but I mean I don't think I
just personally feel like if they would
have just let her like we would just
continue with our lives and people wear
masks and
I just didn't I didn't like the lockdown
at all like really when would you have
implemented the lockdown or when would
you have gone out of the lockdown
I don't think I would have put us in a
lockdown at all at all I think it would
just you know keep keep your distance
you know but like lock people down do
you think there's a disease that maybe
we should lock down for
like if there's something that spreads
through the air and is killing a bunch
of people yeah of course like if that's
what was happening like and people were
like dying left and right yeah I mean
I'm this might be selfish to me and I
don't want to piss off anybody that lost
anybody any family members or anything
like that but I mean I only know if like
a couple people that got it and died
right yeah but it's not like a
statistical analysis yeah it's just like
yeah I don't know I just have a
different perspective on death because
of like when I worked for the coroner's
office you know like I just I'm more
comfortable with it like it's part of
life it's part of death you know as
[ __ ] up as it might be to say some
people more people die you know you know
I mean but I mean the point of a society
should probably be to keep as many
people alive as possible and if you have
to like not
to be able to go to Cinnabon as much as
you want then yeah but do you think it
was all that was do you think it was as
bad uh as bad as it was to justify the
restraints that was put on the world I
think the restraints were worse than
they should have been because we didn't
give money to people we had the paycheck
protection program that all went to the
corrupt businesses because that's
uh the ethos of our country is like try
to steal as much money from everyone
else as possible yeah I know I
understand that but I'm just saying like
for the actual yeah you think it was
fine yeah lockdowns should be a thing
they did it in Korea they did it in
Japan they did it in other countries and
they did it everywhere yeah it was
worldwide and they had much better
responses and fewer deaths and fewer
cases and we were kind of a petri dish
that
covet could like experiment and then
spread to the rest of the world so I
don't know how many people died because
of that but you know I mean if you don't
want to
quarantine then
that's that's on you like if that's the
kind of world that you if that's the
kind of country that's that's what you
want to do as a country then you should
be able to decide to you know let it
spread if you want
but I mean if it affects other people
then it's like people are not going to
be very happy about it yeah
I don't know it just it was weird to me
because I had an essential job like my
business business was essential so I
still went to work every day I still did
the everyday life but then I was just
forced to go home it's like being
grounded you know so I mean it's like it
wasn't to me it was like
the only thing I couldn't do was have
like on a normal life all I could do is
go to work and go at home you know like
so I mean maybe I would have felt
differently if I was in a position where
I had to be where I was locked down and
quarantined the entire time but even
during quarantine I was forced to be
around public you should have been like
[ __ ] given a stipend or like an added
bonus but Hazard money yeah yeah went to
[ __ ] whoever the CEOs I think like uh
if you want to engage with Society you
have to do it on society's terms like
you can still do whatever you want but
if you want to uh you know interact with
people in society that you should uh
like the society has some requirements
yeah like all the things that you can do
alone you can still do yeah I like the
guy getting arrested for surfing you
know
like that's like he's he was definitely
nobody was around him for six feet you
know right but if everyone is doing that
if they they're like oh the beaches are
open yeah then it's like they can get
into contact with each other
but yeah I mean maybe one guy surfing is
like it looks looks bad it looks bad to
arrest him
but yeah I mean if you're I feel like we
didn't really know how to prevent the
disease we're just like wash your hands
do this do that but we didn't really
know how to do it and now we kind of
know like oh it spread to the air that
means avoid air contact with other
people yeah and uh we can do a little
more intelligently and we're sort of
threw the baby out with the bathwater
with some of the policies but I think it
was worth worth the price that we paid
to maybe have a couple more grandpas
kicking around yeah so I mean for them I
mean for the aspect of like family and
love and stuff no one wants to lose
loved one and I don't wish anybody to
have to lose the loved one because of
like yeah any sooner than that their
time but at the same time like I'm just
earlier with it being a part of life and
you know population it would help pop it
would have helped population control a
little bit
well so what a [ __ ] uh guy with the
machete running around an elderly folks
home that's true yeah I used to work in
one of those too you worked everywhere
where what was your essential job uh it
was the auto glass business the family
business like people needed to fix their
window with their cars because people
still had to drive around and go to work
and do stuff and so it was considered
essential and everything is essential
yeah really yeah so I mean we were
considered essential got to stay open
but it was shitty because like that
perspective sucks like going to a place
where the public walks in then on top of
that you have to look like an [ __ ] to
everybody and be like put your mask on
because like you don't personally care
the mask is on or off but there's other
people in the business anyone it's your
family business something you run like
you know having a dad that reads reviews
you know he's just like what do you mean
read your views reads reviews
like that you know people I went in and
they didn't have any mess yeah no mess
on you know stuff like that it just it
makes you be like a type of because
everyone else is doing it it makes you
be like a type of person that's really
not you and then at the same time like
you're coming in and seeing all these
people acting like [ __ ] you have no
control over because they're mad about
the mandates and they're taking out on
you because you're doing what you need
to do to stay open so the guy that comes
by and inspection I agree with you yeah
I don't like math I'm an anti-mass group
yeah I agree with you I don't like this
but also this is like this is this is
what puts food on the table you know
it's like well do you think masks are
that big of a deal like why does
everyone need to not wear a mask
I mean I don't think they're that big of
a deal they're just they're not they're
just like if you don't want to wear them
you should I mean
you're taking it it's your own risk you
know right but the thing is to be
spreading it easier to other people yeah
but people I mean the masks how well did
they really work I mean people still got
it wearing masks and I mean I was
wearing masks maybe less but maybe not
as maybe not as less you know if only
there were scientists that study this
yeah
I just feel like it was important report
[Music]
it was a breakdown in the way we run our
[ __ ] it was like
the people that are in charge of finding
out if Mass Works do we listen to them
or do we just ignore them and say ah
there's corrupt the people that are in
charge of vaccines do they know their
[ __ ] or should we not listen to them
it's like we all have our specialty in
society like Auto Glass like someone was
like I don't think that you did it right
because I read it about it yeah and we
got that all the time people do that
[ __ ] all the time yeah they think they
know what they're talking about and it's
like friction like it doesn't a society
like that doesn't work it's like oh you
you didn't plummet right I read that
you're supposed to pump it like this
well I've been doing Plumbing for
however long yeah like at certain point
you should trust each other to do their
job and you do your job and if you
there's trust it works but if there's no
trust then you have to be good at
everything you have to be good at Auto
Glass and plumbing and like if you could
just trust people and that's what a lot
of other countries have that I think
America doesn't which is great because
now we're suspicious and it's harder to
like [ __ ] us over but that comes at a
price yeah
look at that
it's just yeah it's the cards were dealt
and we just have to learn how to play
with them right yeah what are you gonna
do with your cards
just gonna I'm gonna keep hitting
keep hitting until I get to 21 you know
because that's how it works
the more you hit the closer you get yeah
I mean you just gotta keep going man
yeah all you can do is move forward and
you said you did a lot of shows now you
did Less open mics yeah I don't know a
little combination of just me going out
and being like I don't have really like
I wanted to make sure I'm well slept for
like work and not get fired because it's
just like
don't know just it's nice to have like a
little chunk of money coming in
guaranteed like yeah this pays the bills
and I like being there and so and then
it's just more about going to doing
meaningful sets you know and I was
finding that going to these open mics
we'd go and they just they weren't all
that meaningful like if I had something
new I wanted to work out there was no
one there to listen to them you know
like really you know it's they'll put
the open mic scene is brutal here you
know I mean yeah you've been doing
comedy just as long as I have I mean
you've come through Open Mic scene for
just as long and a certain point like if
you're doing if you're doing shows and
getting enough stage stage time for you
phys for your satisfaction like what why
go to open mics that are they're just
going to bring down your self-esteem
about your sets or your jokes or
something you don't get real you have
bad habits yeah you get bad try to
impress people that are like shitty and
dumb and stupid and gloomy and yeah and
it's like I've never gotten but I never
got I'm here working being here and I've
never gotten booked after going to an
open mic you know I got booked asking
people for shows that's how we met I saw
you around the scene it's not like about
the individual Open Mic it's just like
showing face well no that's the thing is
I just go show faced at the shows now
and then sometimes like you know after
like Secret show or something like I'll
hang out there or if I'm performing on
it and then I'll just walk over to like
the creek in the cave after and they
always have a mic going on there on
Thursday so I just hang and I'm always
around and I'm always around at the
spots seeing everyone I need to and
seeing my friends and the people that I
like talking to and meeting new people
and
didn't and then yeah that's about it I
just
balancing my time you know I'm getting
my stage time which is nice I'm lucky
you got on kill Tony you got on the desk
watch show okay yeah done those and then
people been booking me and
um just people are seeing the coffee
show they're like in the coffee show
like they're so I mean it's weird like
I've had two people since I moved here
that aren't comedians are in the comedy
scene like recognize me from my coffee
show which is cool you know nothing
crazy but two people I was like oh
that's cool like yeah it's getting out
there yeah and so like people are
enjoying it and I've been been just
enjoying myself while and doing
everything the art of creating exactly
and then when I do shows you know I'll
do I'll have my sets that I plan out and
I write out my sets and everything and
then like I'll be like all right well
this is a new joke it's gonna go between
this Banger and this Banger you know so
if like it bombs it went after a really
good joke if it bombs then another
really good news coming around try out
new stuff yeah experiments I always like
to try and take a little bit of a risk
you know because you know if you don't
take risks there's no reward yeah
that's fine man the the the journey the
creation the the art of it I think it's
a great journey and it's like the only
Journey really so far yeah that's what
I'm enjoying but all life is and we I
think this is a great art form to to get
into so it's a lot of fun it's
bottomless yeah so it's a lot of fun
you're playing with the audience
sometimes I can't believe this is like
my life I get to do this you know yeah
and I mean it's still I'm still striving
for it to get better to do it more
consistently in front of more like do
more do as many meaningful sets as
possible you know
yeah that's awesome
yeah I uh hope to have that attitude as
well yeah I like to think that I do I'm
just trying to get on kill Tony again
and become a be your alternate regular
you know like David Lucas has Ellis I'll
be your alternate regular
well yeah I mean do you have any more
water I think that you can do
a lot of great comedy not necessarily
take my job but oh no I didn't say take
your dollars so just be there for when
you can't make it you know
well I think that uh that's you don't
have to get that to be happy but I don't
have to get it it'd be a nice goal but
it's not not I feel like I'm pretty
happy here like I can honestly say that
I'm enjoying my life at the moment right
it's there's some struggles involved but
I mean it's only creating it's only
building character and making me better
yeah yeah
um well yeah I'm uh I think that's that
we should call it you're good I'm good
man thanks for having me yeah